Hello everyone, I'm Amir, I'm here with my
Italian friend Luca, and this time we want to
do an interview in Spanish,
Toluca, like this, only very well,
your ideal, that's fine, thank you, well, nothing
special, not in the first video that you made
in Spanish, you did that there was no time
to  talk about all your experiences
with languages ​​and all the
curiosities, so we are going to try to
take advantage of this time now to talk
about your experiences in Spain, okay, well,
yes,
for example, when I made the first video,
the one where I speak about languages, I was in
Barcelona, ​​I was in  Erasmus Barcelona
over there Yes and I stayed in Barcelona I
stayed for five or less months in five or
six months and yes yes for that reason well I can
say that I was in Spain but that I
was more in Catalonia
because for example people say well  You
speak Spanish but when I tell the
Spanish that they lived in Spanish and it's
good, that's why you speak
Spanish and I answer,
well, it's the  It's true that in
Barcelona when I was in Barcelona
now most of the time other languages
but Spanish not much, so yes,
well, to put it from my point of
view, it's written abroad and
well, but well I
remember that in your first recordings
on your youtube page you said that
you had never lived outside your own
country in your in one of the first
recordings like this you had never
left your own country before
and yes yes that is, I had known that if he had
left he had left my country
but no, not to live on vacations and on
vacations throughout Europe more or less it's
a for example I don't know in Sweden in
England in Germany and everything but
I always stayed for a few days and
then returned home that is, it was the
first time so I can  say that it was the
first time when I went to Barcelona
that I left and that I left the country to
live in another place, yes,
and tell me why you made the decision
to go to Catalonia.
uivoco
well he was telling me that he was one
of the exchange programs
well it was always like that it
was an erasmus exchange program
the problem with erasmus exchange is
that when I decided to do it it was a
little later that they were
truly the last year of
university  and he was telling me
that it was not easy to find an
erasmus like that because the problem is that the
program features you have to do a
series of bureaucratic things that are
heavy, very heavy, you know there is a
well-known movie that you see in
Spanish but
Whatever the guy says, you are
facing incredible bureaucratic challenges, not
in France, so I don't know if you had to
prepare the papers, but the problem
was the problem is that you also had
to have a teacher available to
tell you, well, you can do it and  I
found a person of one. I think
he is the coolest professor in the
faculty, calmer, but this
professor only had contacts.  cough with two
universities in the European territory
that were the universe a school in
France not far from paris and another school
that was in catalonia city in
barcelona or paris or barcelona
and well well I said well we have to
decide what
the possibility  The idea of ​​going to Paris was
specific, but I was not saying
that I preferred a more Mediterranean country the
first time I left to live in a
place and I already knew Barcelona and
for when the good environment would be
more or less similar to my country
And there it is, yes, of course, yes, because
Barcelona is very similar, it is not far
from Italy, it is beautiful and a little more
by plane, and well, the mentality is very
much more similar to the
Italian mentality than the mentality for Argentina and
China, for that reason, well.  In general, if
you want to go abroad, I have no
problem dealing with a
completely different mentality, but
I don't know, and four or five
years ago I decided to go to Barcelona, ​​which I already had.  I went
to Barcelona, ​​friends, friends, I had
met people here in Rome and
then I left and stayed for 5 or 5 months,
okay, okay, and I also pointed out that,
curiously, during your stay, you didn't
speak much Spanish despite the
fact that Barcelona is  a very
cosmopolitan city I imagine
if they found you spent a lot of time
speaking in German and French just
because as I always say in my
videos in general in my life what
counts most for languages ​​is not so much
the place where you are so well
this  It is important, but also
the people with whom you meet
with whom, for example, you go out to have
a drink or you don't live that one and I was
with two Italians I lived with two
Italians from the south and a woman from Malaga who
was Spanish who only speaks Spanish but
I had no contact with her but she
worked all day long, then she would come
back and she was tired and well,
we would talk a bit but to develop
your language skills  you have to
talk a lot have a lot of contact go out
with people
stay for hours chatting with people
you know and this did not have so they
had other friends my french girlfriend
we were speaking in french or
elsewhere and regarding german
in barcelona a lot of french a lot
Italian a lot of English also English
with other friends but German not
much German to tell the truth I'm not
speaking a lot now in Paris but
not much in Barcelona
and well the next question well
come on there was well we know that there was
a historical rivalry we indicate like this and well
there  Yes, there was a
linguistic rivalry and also a football one, and
according to your opinion, no, well, this continues to
happen today.
Without a doubt, you know when, when I speak
with Spaniards from other parts of Spain
and with Barcelonans, I always started this
discussion when I was in Barcelona.
The incredible thing is that many
many discussions were mainly
about Castilian and Catalan
Catalan is a dialect
is a  language because and we are talking
about politics etc. lately it is
very lately for example I
talked with a friend who is telling me
that in Catalonia
there is a law that is, there is no law
but there is a general attitude of protection
and principle if it is a
linguistic protection but  at the same
time he says he is telling me
my friend was commenting and I don't know why
not now I'm not around but he tells me
that there is a Catalan policy according to
which Catalan has to be not only the
official language but Spanish is
seen as a problem as an obstacle and
this seems a bit strange to
me because I don't know I stayed there for
only five months it is not enough to
know the entire linguistic situation
etc. no
this seemed very strange to me it is not
saying that not many many people  I could
have a fine and if they put things in
Spanish the butcher shop says in a
butcher shop in Spanish not even with a
fine that didn't seem to be closed and
also that in Catalonia because of the  For example, you
can't work if I don't, either you can
work for those who are able to speak and they won't get it.
That's why it's very important and
classes are also taught in Catalan in schools
and I have to tell you the truth.
The first time I went to Catalonia,
I didn't  I really liked Catalan and the idea of
having to learn another language that
we are in states in Spain and that I had
to take classes in Catalan because it
bothered me a little but when I went
to university and they told me I
said very, very timidly it's  Law of
Forgiveness It is possible to have this class in
Spanish but that's the way
I didn't have it and I just said that like that and
they answered me well you know most of
them I'm very very kind very
kind they answered me calmly
they made me know what the  The problem
is that here we are in Catalonia, classes are given
in Catalan and that's it, and I didn't
have a choice, that is, I couldn't choose
between one and the other, and with my friend
we were discussing that, we were
discussing what
at  At first it bothered me but later
I understood it perfectly and then
here in Paris I had a
Catalan roommate who explained his entire
vision to me and that is, they do it to
preserve their language and I understand it
perfectly, that is, it is an identity and
I  I am a guest in your country and I have to
adapt but if to answer your
question it is true that there are problems of
I don't know about misunderstandings
between the rest of Spain and Catalonia due to
historical cultural misunderstandings and
really there will always be good
provocateurs who  They are going to search since it
continues to provoke, of course, it is not
about football, it also exists, yes, yes, well,
I have an agreement, for example, this one, I
don't know if you remember that when I say it happened
from Madrid to something that's cool, a
little when it happens in Barcelona  or
to barcelona madrid i don't remember he
reads well they threw him a
canvas hip for madrid adri will throw him
a pig's head no good because
because he was captain  not for him he thought
foreign capital not playing for
this of course they were upset yes yes
no but that is proof of the of the of the of
the of the problems that exist between not
only from a historical point of view
but also of everything that is
football of everything and there also a
history of Catalonia fought against against
the central government of Spain I know that
the healthy thing is that they hate each other but the people of
Madrid and the people of Barcelona the people of
Barcelona are two different things
these friends and internal external
let's say it if something else  What we have
seen is that you give me this
link where from one of a video where
I was teaching him how the people of
Madrid see the people of Barcelona as
stingy
what is something else is something else is another law I
don't know if it is a legend but  It's a cliché
that's for sure and how good they are liars. No,
there are things without shots or pipes. The people of
Madrid don't know what they follow.
Also in Italy we have the Romans
are like that the endings are like that the
Sicilians are like that yes it's a bit cool
but that's part of the folklore and well
there are similar things well in each
country and if we think well it's also
good among the people who  He speaks
Russian as his mother tongue
for example and well
maybe in the next interview
in your many in in your video many
South Americans asked you why
you have such a traditional accent and it seems
that they are upset not because of it what
do you think of this well I already told
you  Commenting on the difference
between the accents in Spain and this this
accent problem are more
acute problems between Latin America Latin America
and Spain Yosemite Aliaron no
I didn't know
I wasn't aware of this problem but
making videos on youtube and
then taking a while  little with some with some
americans some colombians
argentines in general i realized
that between spain and mexico and there is one i
don't know it's like a free fight  We
got to me, I didn't realize and for
example, they did uncle because you speak
they don't say uncle but because he speaks
with this accent so traditional as if to
act as if it were like that as if it were a
they are not a disaster well there when
I left  to Madrid two years ago I was
commenting I was talking to a guy
from Colombia who told me you know here in
Colombia if we look at a Spaniard here if
we drink
chatting in Spanish we tease him a
bit because it seems very very very
very strange for us there is that  accent
and many of us don't like it at all and
speaking with the Spaniards they
said no to me he really does
n't like the Argentine accent at all he does
n't like the Colombian accent at all
that's why I personally think this is
a general problem or  It's also in
England. Now I'm going to London
and look at what Luca said. You have to
know that if you speak with an
American accent, most of the British are
going to look at you a little like that
I mean, out of the corner of their eye they end up and they tell you that
you say uncle and that you're so weird, how strange
you are and that happened,
that is, that happened when I was with
Richard when I was visiting Chester
in England, so I realized
that people didn't like him.  not at all the way he
spoke but but I have to tell you that
I am not American that is why when I
say that I am not American they
say what they say is well that what is not
American but it is true that
especially with the former colonies or with
countries that had  a common history and
a difficult history the
conquistadors know and everything maybe that is
also part of of also the fight
for freedom no and the fight for
freedom many things between the
united states between the united states
england and england between between
mexico  Spain between Columbia that this
is normal I think not because as far as I know
it is very difficult to generalize that
the Latin American accent is good it is not
certain that Mexicans do not speak
like Argentines  not everyone has their
personalities and I think that it is
in a way it is a bit paradoxical
because I don't know what is here
and I think that after accents in
general constitute beauty,
preciousness, variety and linguistic richness
is a richness not  It's
not an issue we have
to fight about getting angry. The problem is that
for me it's a heritage, it's not an
inheritance, and it's a cultural heritage, it's
a tradition, and that's why I think we
don't have to fight, it's just a
difference because of  That's good, I understand it,
for example, in my opinion
there are Italian accents that I don't
like at all, well, we are a
very small country, so we are a small country,
we don't have colonies and we had a
couple of colonies, but in general we don't have
others.  countries on the other side of the world
where they speak the same language
in a completely different way because
that's why I don't know but
I understand that some accents you may not
like they sound like e  I understand that they sound well
they may sound I don't know
negative or a little weird or just
weird and I understand that but one
has to respect everyone communication is the
most important thing for me well
that's what that that that's
the most important thing  It's important, yes, it's worth, many
say that being Italian for you,
Spanish is very easy, no, but well, what
do you think, I wouldn't like to be here,
but it's true that it's true that it
's easier for Italians than for
non-English-speaking English
speakers because there are many things
that they are similar for example
the pronunciation the most important thing
is and I'm talking about pronunciation intonation
of pronunciation is
no no the pronunciation apart from if you
are you are similar or the double r but the
easiest thing for us as
Italians is that the vowels have a
vocal quality and here that is similar, saá
is very similar while in English
that is different, so yes, that is why it is
easier, but the integration is
complete  mently different
an Italian speaking Spanish is said one
can say immediately that Italian
and
and in Spanish in some cases it is not an
exception of course well in
most cases if I don't know that is if they
tell me well a little bit of Italian it doesn't
happen no  nothing happens, I don't know about Spanish,
he generally tells me that I speak well,
but not in general, what he wanted to
say is that if you tell me, for example,
that Spanish is very easy, I don't
agree because, above all, on all
advanced levels  I don't know if you're
good, there is this huge of course, that
is, I've seen a lot of people say, well,
I speak, I speak or the language was not spoken,
but the truth is that it
doesn't occur to you in a language,
it's not the same as adding a very
very high when when when you reach
a level like c1 c2 I don't know for
people who don't know that they don't know
c1 c2 or very advanced levels or it is almost
negative well
it's something else Spanish is a
language that has a lot  of
grammatical nuances and things that are not are not
obvious they are not easy at all they are not
easy at all and that is why to get
there any language that is Spanish that
is Russian any language even if it is the
language most similar to yours is is
requires time  Efforts,
attention, and all that's why I say yes, it's
easy to speak broken Spanish, but it's
difficult to reach a very high level and not
make mistakes, then make mistakes
because there are what in English are called
false friends, not false friends, and
that's why in Italian  In French,
especially when you reach a certain level and
want to express yourself in a precise,
very precise way, it is very possible and very
likely to make a lot of
mistakes because you think that is said in
Italian, so it has to
be said in Spanish in the same way and
not  It's like this or Shanghai Lai in China,
that
's why, like, as I've already said,
it's relatively easy to
talk but speaking well isn't difficult in
any language.  to the same as for
that reason I say that the same as everything the same
as because it is the same as Spanish or
Italian etc. well and good to
let's move on to the next question
all the Spanish classes on skype and
that a person that a person can
teach a language that  it is not yours
visuals what is your opinion well
there are a lot of people who say that the
teachers of a language should
be native speakers of that language
where that language and
I totally agree with this because I think that as soon as
As a foreigner, one has the potential
as a person who has learned another
language, knows about the difficulties,
knows the difficulties
that a foreigner faces, and therefore,
if the teacher knows how to
speak very well, knows
the language very well  foreigner I think it is
an advantage to be a foreigner after
having traveled such a long road, well,
if you want to put in so much time, not
to reach the level of one
of  two I think that if it has been answered
as I was commenting before to reach
a certain level the problem is
that the path is very long
so you have made a lot of
efforts once and then it is already there and
then they know what one has to  one
would have to do to reach the same
level and a native a native did not have
these gestures problems well he is a
native that is why
I think that if a teacher is
prepared for me the most important thing
is the human quality of the teacher the
professional quality of knowledge
Linguistic well, that is obvious, but
there are natives who do not know how to teach their
language and there are foreigners who now
teach them very well, so it
is not necessarily a thing for me, it is
an advantage to be foreigners later if
there is a native who is aware of their
language because many  You know the problem
is that many many say that is my
language but the language
does not belong to anyone the language is a
tool that is used it is not that
once I discussed  you with a Frenchman who was
saying it well you know French is my
language that's why it's mine it belongs to me I
said it's not that it belongs to you it's that you
use it it's that different it's not that if
you're French you have more right to
speak French than  I know
maybe you don't know him better, you speak better to us but
not necessarily there I am sure
that there are foreigners who give classes
I don't know French, for example, they know
some nuances better than French than
the French or the Spanish that the
natives speak  In general, that's why yes, to
answer your question, if for me being
a foreigner and teaching languages ​​is
perfectly possible and compatible with
general teaching,
I agree,
and well, perhaps the last question is
good, a little philosophical, no,
looking back
55 years later, well.  Do you more or less think
that it was a useful experience for you?
Bond, that is, from a
cultural point of view, or from a professional point of view,
I
eat well as part of  your
linguistic development let's say
that making videos on youtube
well, having lived in catalonia
yes, without a doubt, living in two other
places opens up has helped you a lot to
discover some things,
not only the language, but also the
places, the attitudes, the mentality, the
trifles and you learn to discover
yourself also through the sites that I
recommend to everyone on Erasmus and 20
years ago for example it was
for something that perhaps the best 10 years
did not do very few and now
everyone does it because it is  Part of
the I saw there are universities that
impose it that say you have to spend six
months or a year abroad because it
is a way of form it is a
training that is part of experience they
are not know not only not only we have to
give instructions and knowledge  to the
students in general but to give
possibilities they discovered the world and
this is particularly important not
only for the linguistic development that
is a consequence but also  Also for the
human development
of a person, that is why I
advise everyone and I think that it is a
cultural heritage that has accumulated. I
am now in France.
I have to tell you that
yes, they are stages of life that I
advise everyone, so yes.  you stay if
you want to stay in italy no please
these seaweeds please leave
italy
for me lucas thank you very much for this
interview it was a pleasure chatting
with you and we'll talk again
well in russian maxim next the next one
will be russian and about your country
thank you all revenge